this capsule we will see pruning
alfa beta so when we saw the jaws
max mini pace is still not bad
there and so we would like on power
accelerate accelerate the associated research
to the minimax algorithm what we are going to see
in the next capsule including
these two these different approaches
to do this acceleration is the
first that we will see will allow
to maintain the accuracy of the solution
that is to say once again have a
algorithm that allows us to get
the optimal action for another seal and
have a second approach that she's going
to be of a certain approximation so
we will actually lose the optimality of
our joy but it allowed me to have
as many improvements as we need
for example in a context one has to
take an action in real time so
in this capsule
we will see more precisely the first
body to know a cock that keeps
the accuracy of the solution that
is what is called pruning
alpha beta - will do in English forgiveness
alphabet the prow ning and the idea here that
is going to be actually identifying paths
which are explored unnecessarily in order to
just do not explore them and so
reduce the amount calculation in our
research to illustrate the idea behind
alpha concrete is going to see a very simple case
where we finally have a part where max plays a
turn then mine plays a trick and then
finally the game ends and
the idea behind the station alfa beta this is
that at any time we will maintain a
kind of confidence interval so a
interval on the minimax values
possible so the values ​​actually
of utility that are attainable
according to which part of the graffiti that explored
until now
so it's a kind of interval that
allows us to maintain our certainty
on what is the worst that max could
reach and what is it better than max
could reach at any time from the
research
and when we will want to offend
identify places from the clouds
states parties that are in contradiction
with
this lotion confidence interval so
let's go step by step
at the very beginning of the algorithm we are going
initialize our interval on
possible values ​​of the minimum max value
has less finished well the lack of
means finished at more infinity they have
closed measure we are going to execute
the algorithm we will spend this interval
there from one place to another so that as
and as we go through our soul
we are able to detect in a
internal that has some contradiction
that we do not need to continue
to do our exploration so at all
start one to turn max who calls his sa
first action his first our
successors and asks that it is for
this we successor there the value mini max
so this calls ends so we have a
call of phantom a roissy stand and
have wanted to spend the gap on
max mini values ​​- and ends up more
infinity on the site ends makes the
same thing so he recursively
he will call his first action is
called tomax what will bring us to this
no one here because it's a bit of a
final tomax will return 3 and so mine
will observe that his call to max turn which
is the call that returns 3 and will put
its internal minimal uselessness
so will start calculating its value
of its minimax value at this point if this
so we know since mines minimize
utility we know that the value
minimal to xv has returned to this everywhere
to mines by this void vote is
necessarily smaller than or equal to 3
means that we can update
our interval on values
possible of the max mini value between
other mines will be able to update the
upper bound of this interval so
we now know that the value of
part of the mini max pageantry is located
between less defined and 3
then two men finish ends going
call will explore his second success
it is the second action that is associated
to whom corresponds to a final that a
utility of 12 in observation that puts me
not up to date its its value its better
min max value we do not update
also that she is the interval on
the minimax walls of the part
third faction so we arise in
this example if there are three actions
possible for each player
we were 8 so we finished
the iterations on actions at the level
of a mine and then we return
utility of troy that would correspond to
take this action monday if we
then go back to this part of
running around maxi just having the
min max value for this successor
here and then which maximizes so he
observe that it does not return 3 so
he knows that the value its minimax value
at the level of this draw may have more
big or equal to 3 so we can put to
day our the interval at this level
also on the mini max value of the
part by updating
in this case the lower bound
since it's a maximum income
attempt in fact to maximize the utility and
so we know that at this level too
mini maxis value dress of three or more
we agree to update our intervals
the max node then observes or explores
so his second action what we
brings to this one is passed the
current value of our kid interval
between 3 and more infinity we come to this
level 6th round so that's the result
of max who calls everything to mines for
that we are there and we pass without the values
of the interval it is to the mines him
must explore his children to him that's
our successors so call him
now tomac on his first
successor who is this here since
it's a final it returns the shot
was the utility that returns and then c2
to snow if what is observed is that the
min max value that will be calculated which
would be calculated by exploring all the
kids are going to be necessarily more
small or equal to 2 however a
contradiction with the fact that until
now we know that the minimum value
max of the party at the root is going to
find between 3 and infinity so that wants
to say that even his exploit is a law
here then we could imagine a part
more complex and the more towers that
may have many more under
here in this case this is an example
play so we have a part to only
two rounds but so since we observe a
also argued that what will calculate this
which will be returned as by the mini
maxi will necessarily be more than 2
but we know that at the level of the parent
the lake bar is expected
either three or more
so when it's exploration
from the rest of the nude success seems so
that's why x and xi assume
we do not see these children explored
then we come to the level of the max
since we stopped the exploration at the bottom
max will now explore his third
action his third does not arouse
successor he will spend the interval of
their mini max for the root part
mines in turn call max for his
first child his first successor
in this case if it happens to be a
final so round max will go back
the usefulness of a num initie observes
a utility that returns and 14 and
so he knows that his value has also sounded
laval a minima that will necessarily
smaller or equal to 14 so we can
update the interval on which
values ​​could take the helm to
max mine of the part we know now
that it will be between 3 or 14
so that makes fourteen would correspond to
if the others do not here and is bigger
we would fall 14 bis actually here
ben max tells irene action that
would bring a utility of 14 so this
would be in the best case for max
in the worst case the other children
here for mines would be worse than three
so three or so so that would be
the worst case that would allow us
to reach that part of the bank of
the second child interval which is
generated is so it's a final
and the uselessness of 5
so now at cenon here too that his
dot to be smaller than or equal to 5 against
small this our downstream by changing the
upper bound finally last
action the action of 2
in this case too we would have a
contradiction with our interval this
that they would stop the exploration but
anyway this is the last action
so art exploration is
necessarily and that means that
at the root level the best
lavalas minimax value so the action that
allows us to achieve utility that is
the largest assuming that mines and
rational and optimal would be 3 and
would correspond to having taken 17 action
also so we notice with this
reasoning there and we move on to
information on an interval of
possible values ​​of the minimum max value
for the part one is able to
delegate the search so eliminate
some certain explorations of
notable search and therefore to do
a calculation that is more efficient
we see here a pseudo code of
the algorithm and before moving on to
through I'm going to do right now
notice that it's like the algorithm
put the minimax booth that we saw in
a previous capsule but what changes
that's what's framed here now
we must pass alpha and beta values
alpha corresponds to the lower bound
pub and at the top of the notes
interval all the name the alfa range
beta so that must have been there at
each of the routines each of the
functions and we have two more
additional operations to be done when
max or mines makes a selection of the
best action learns when trying to
find the action that has a bar
max the lowest possible
so let's go through his actions his
uses or their imax algorithm I'm going
start with mean as it's a
body we talked about a bit more in
the example so undermines what makes more
in fact it is that after getting
the utility of max towers and possibly
if a mother utility to have updated
its utility that consider returning on
will watch what this utility is there
in contradiction with monterrey
the interval and among others is that
it is a utility that is much better
that the minimum value
of the real mini max for the whole
part according to our current interval
so is alpha it's the lower bound
of my intervals
so if I have a utility value that
is already lower than I can
guarantee to be the smallest mini value
max for the whole party
I know I can stop
exploration and I'm going back in
this case also booed the action at but of
anyway it's going to be ignored by by
the call at the top which is a call of
tournhac what they call tomine
know ignore because it's going to be a
action that is not as good as the
previous
so it's a default return on
could have actually returned alpha too
it's the same thing and if
we did not have this stop condition
the time we will update the beast so
the upper limit will be updated
by the player's turn mines and we do
that simply by taking the minimum
between the current upper bound and
the utility currently considered the mother
currently uses found by the
player mine the same way the player
max yes will rather be a
comparison with beta cracked to do
a kalfat comparison so we will do
a comparison that the upper bound
check that we have not found a
utility that is better than the maximum
of utility or min max value
find so far if this is the
case we will stop the exploration for
you return the utility find up
now in this in the turn the tower
current of max and otherwise we will put to
day the lfh to the lower bound in
taking the max between alfa and
the utility and the best activity
was currently per tour max onu
current in um so that's
the algorithm a small local of
the alfa beta pruning algorithm that
allows that makes a modification of
the max mini booth but that allow
to explore - we in search of a
notable research
some properties of alfa pruning
beta the first thing is that it
does not affect the final result of
the mini max algorithm ie
it really falls back on true value
it calculates well and truly the mini value
max as previously defined
and it gives us the action
which associated with this minimum value will be
so the best action to take if we
suppose our opponent and
rational and optimal for what
computing time in the worst of
alpha beta body will look at another one
times beal am opus d allah do not like
internal in the algorithm like the
max mini sentry box I remind that lower
the maximum number of shares for
guys at every step that m sila the
depth of notable search so
the maximum number of shots to finish
a part
on the other hand, if we explore our
successors in a good scheduling
it's a scheduling that allows us
to have the most elimination possible
of way explore in the best of
case if we knew the cough the moment
what is the island the successor we should
first explore the action considered
first in order to get us done
a most optimal release
we could reach a complexity that
would be of the order of b to hate on
two what does that mean is that
at the same time we will be able
to explore research purposes in
depth twice as deep as
with the algorithm and minimath
ok which is still a gain
meaningful that allow us to see
twice in the future for
make our decision on the best
action learns but that's a case a
not very idealistic
whereas we assume we are
able to have the best successor
in terms of punctuality the cost
way of a little more representative in
what if we still have a reduction
that is to say, we will be at home
three quarters of a meter